ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครู
เรียมโหนี้เป็นวีดีโอแรกเลยนะที่ครูฟ้า
กับคนเลี่ยมสอนด้วยกันใจแล้วอุ้ยคนรู้แบบ
คุณรู้
ก็ไว้วีดีโอแรกใช่ไหมนักเรียนก็
เซอร์ไพรส์คะครูบาก็เซอร์ไพรส์ก็ไปให้เออ
เออดีมากเลยวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันอะไรคะ
หมูป่าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันพุธค่ะนี้วัน
พุธเดิมเขียนให้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่วัน
ที่ 3 ค่ะวันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมคีย์สิงหันต์ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  565
เคแล้วปีกคศนะคะเมื่อปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะโอเค
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะลูกจ๋าตอนนี้เวลา 14:00
น
14:00 นตรงเลยใช่ไหมคะ
24 นาทีค่ะ 24 นาที
รู้สึกหิวข้าวจังเลยอ่ะคุณเรียมยังไม่ได้
กินข้าวหรอคะกินแล้วค่ะ
กินแล้วครัวอ่านนักเรียนหิวอยู่ใช่ไหมคะ
คุณไม่เข้าใจค่ะว่าที่กูเขาก็กินข้าวแล้ว
แต่ก็หิวนะอ่ะไม่เป็นไรถ้ากินข้าวแล้วครู
ฟ้าก็กินข้าวแล้ววันนี้เนี่ยก็เลยมานั่ง
คุยกับครูเรียมแล้วก็มีเรื่องมาเล่าให้
ฟัง
ลูกค้ามีเรื่องอะไรมันเล่าให้เดี๋ยวฟัง
ค่ะครูฟ้านี่นะคะอ่าเป็นคนที่ชอบอ่าน
หนังสือ
ตัวการ์ตูนนักเรียนฟังก่อนนะซื้อการ์ตูน
ไม่ออกรถช่องอ่านหนังสือเหรอเอาตัว
การ์ตูนนะคะแล้วก็หนังสือนิทานใช่ไหมที่ 5
เหมือนพก Cinderella  Snow  White หรือ
ว่าที่กูฟ้าเอามาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังอ่า
นิทานของคันแอนเดอร์สัน
ว้าวแบบไม่รู้จัก
แต่ถ้าเกิดใหม่ชอบฟังนิทานฟังการ์ตูนก็คง
จะรู้จักก็น่าจะรู้จักนะคะครูก็ชอบนะมัน
เป็นนิทานที่แบบคิดว่าผู้ใหญ่ก็ฟังได้
เด็กก็ฟังได้อะไรเงี้ยนะคะแล้วก็คิดว่า
เองปูปลาไม่ค่อยเอานิทานไทยมาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฟังเลยวันนี้ก็เลยไปหาอ่านนี่มันมี
นิทานไทยเรื่องไหนที่
ฟังแล้วโอเคฟังแล้วรู้สึกสนุกมาให้นัก
เรียนฟังกับครูเรียวก็ยังค่ะที่สำคัญก็
คือเล่าได้ใน 20 นาที
[เพลง]
ตอนนิทานไทยอย่างยาวมากต้องได้ใน 20 นาที
นักเรียนนิทานเรื่องนี้นี้ชื่อว่า
พิกุลทอง
ครีมเครดิตไหมเคยได้ยินมันค่ะถือฟ้าคน
ท้องทาหญิงคนนึง
ใช่ค่ะเป็นนิทานเป็น Sorry ของผู้หญิงคน
นึงเออเป็นผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
คุณฟ้าผู้หญิงคนนี้ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงปกติมะ
ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงธรรมดาว่าคุณฟ้าเนี่ยกับครู
เรียนเป็นผู้หญิงแต่เราในเป็นผู้หญิง
ธรรมดานะคะผู้หญิงมันได้ชื่อว่าพี่กุล
ชื่อพิกุลเพราะจริงแล้วเนี่ยพิกุลเนี่ย
เป็นดอกไม้ใช่ไหมคะคุณเรียมเป็นดอกไม้ให้
เป็นดอกไม้แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะคือปลาในคะใช้
หมอในหอเป็นดอกไม้แบบนี้เออดอกไอ้อย่าง
นี้เลยชื่อพิมพ์กุ้งเอาชื่อเหมือนดอกไม้
เฉยๆใช่ไหมคะชื่อเหมือนดอกไม้แล้วก็ที่
ชื่อพิกุลเนี่ยเพราะว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เวลา
พูดจะมีดอกพิกุลออกมาจากป่าต5หาจะปกตินะ
คะทุกคนใช่คนนะทำไมพูดแล้วมีดอกพิกุลออก
มาล่ะเนี่ยนิทานไทยเวลาพูดมีดอกแต่ดอก
พิกุลเนี่ยไม่ใช่ดอกพิกุลธรรมดานะเรียน
เป็นดอกพิกุลทองด้วยค่ะเรียมดอกพิกุลทอง
แบบนี้
ใช่เราเลี้ยงว้าวดีมากเลยนะคะถือว่าเป็น
เรื่องที่ดีนะคะว่าดอกพิกุลทองเนี่ยมัน
แพงใช่นักเรียนหรอแล้วก็เอาไปขายเหรอเอา
ไปขายนะว่าจะเก็บไปสายนะเอาเงินซึ่งผู้
หญิงวันนี้ก็จะพูดจะมีดอกพิกุลทองออกมา
จากปาก
ไม่ธรรมดาเลยนะแล้วก็มีอีกหนึ่งอย่างก็
คือผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยมีผม
แน่นอนผู้หญิงพูดมีผมนะให้พี่ผมผู้ชายก็
มีไม่ใช่ก็มีแต่ผมเนี่ยหอมด้วยอ่ะ
เวลาดมแล้วหอม
อบถ้าเกิดแบบไม่ไม่สระผมหลายๆวันก็ยังขอ
มีไหมคะก็ยังหอมอยู่เองหรอดีจังเลยใช่
มั้ยอะเมซิ่งไทยแลนด์ไว้ทั้งเนียนๆถ้า
เกิดเปลี่ยนเป็นที่คุณทองและจะไม่สระผม
เลย
ใจอ่ะไม่ต้องอาบน้ำไปบ่อยก็ได้นะเพราะว่า
ผมหอมมากก็เลยเป็น Sorry ของพิกุลทองนั่น
แหละผู้หญิงที่ชื่อว่าพิกุลทองค่ะ
พิกุลทองเนี่ยเป็นเจ้าหญิงนี้
ว่าเจ้าหญิงมหานักเรียนก็คือมีคุณพ่อเป็น
พระราชาใช่ไหมเป็นขิงน้องเป็นพระราชาแล้ว
ก็มีคุณแม่เป็นพระราชินีพี่กดท้องก็เลย
เป็นเจ้าหญิง
ซึ่ง
ก็เป็นเจ้าหญิงอยู่ในวางเนื้อหาเป็นเจ้า
หญิงอยู่ในวังกูเพราะว่านิดหนึ่งของวัน
ที่ 1 เนาะได้ค่ะอันนี้คุณพ่อ
อันนี้คือไม่ใช่สับปะรดนะนี่นี้คุณแม่
แล้วก็เป็นเจ้าหญิง
หลวงพ่อเป็น King ก็จะมีมงกุฏมีมงกุฎ
มงกุฎใช่ไหมมีเขาเป็นพระราชาขอโทษค่ะแล้ว
ก็คุณแม่อ่าคุณแม่ก็เป็นเจ้าพระราชินี
เหมือนกัน
1 พิกุลก็เลยเป็นเจ้าหญิง
มีมงกุฎมงกุฎมงกุฎแล้วก็อยู่ในเป็นพระ
ราชวังแล้วอยู่ในวางอยู่ขอฟัง
ฟังก็จะเป็นอย่างเงี้ยบ้านใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมนัก
เรียนเพราะว่าเป็นเจ้าหญิงนะคะอยู่ในหวัง
อ่ะนี่เนี่ยมีอยู่วันนึงที่คุณก็ก็คิด
อยากอาบน้ำ
ปกติแล้วเนี่ยเวลานักเรียนอาบน้ำมันก็จะ
ไปห้องน้ำแล้วนี่ก็ไปอาบน้ำอาบน้ำสระผม
ไม่ใช่มะแต่นิทานอันนี้เนี่ยมันนานแล้ว
โคเรียมนานมาก
เมื่อก่อนประเทศไทยอาจจะไม่ได้มีห้องน้ำ
ไม่ได้อาบน้ำในห้องน้ำได้พิกุลเนี่ยก็เลย
ต้องไปอาบน้ำที่แม่น้ำ
เมยแม่น้ำเหมือนแม่น้ำมิสซิสซิปปีไงก็ไม่
น้ำมั้ยแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
ใช่น้ำโขงไม่ต้องโขงถูกต้องค่ะพี่คุณก็
เลยไปอาบน้ำที่แม่น้ำ
เกาะไปไปกับก็จะต้องมีคนดูแลเนอะเพราะว่า
เป็นเจ้าหญิงไม่ใช่ไหมคะเป็นเจ้าหญิงก็จะ
มีโคนี่คนคนเดียวไม่ได้ไปคนเดียวค่ะครู
เรียมมีคนๆไปด้วยเยอะๆไม่อาบน้ำกันที่นี่
เนี่ยระหว่างที่พิกุลกำลังอาบน้ำอาบน้ำ
อยู่นะคะก็มี
แร้งค์ไปเลยแรงอย่างนี้ว่ะนักเรียนรู้จัก
ใช่ไหมแรงเนี่ยอาหารที่แร้งกินก็คือ
อะไรที่ปลายแล้วอ่ะหมาตายแมวตายหนูตาย
หรือว่าอะไรที่ตายแล้วเหม็น
แรงชอบกินอะไรเหม็นๆมีคนตายแรงก็กินเนาะ
ถ้ากินก่อน
ใช่ครับแรงตัวนี้เนี่ยก็คิดเองวันนี้
ออกไปหาอะไรกินดีไหมหน้า
และก็เลยคิดว่าโอเคงั้นออกไปทำไรกินดี
กว่าแล้วแร้งเนี่ยพระราชาแรงนะไม่ต้อง
อ่านชาแรงพระราชาด้วยนะคะแรกนี่เป็นแบบ
เหมือนนกให้อย่างนี้นะใช่ไปแบบเพียงเป็น
พระราชาแบบที่ครูฟ้าหมายถึงก็คือพระราชา
ที่มีมงกุฎที่เป็น King หรอใช่แล้วค่ะ
เพราะว่านิทานภาษานิทานไทยค่ะนักเรียน
ภาษาไทยนิทานไทยว่าก่อนเนี่ยก็จะเป็นแบบ
อย่างเงี้ยแรงแล้วก็จะไม่ใช่แรงธรรมดา
เป็นพระราชาแล้งถ้าเกิดเราเรียกเราไม่
เรียกพระราชาและเราเรียกพญาแล้งพญาแปลว่า
ใหญ่มี Power จะใช่ไหมเป็นพญานะคะเอ่อ
ใหญ่ที่สุดอันดับหนึ่งพญาแร้งเดี๋ยวก็ออก
มาหาอะไรกินแถวๆแม่น้ำ
ก็บินมาเรื่อยๆบินบินบินมาแล้วก็เห็นว่า
ในแม่น้ำเนี่ยมันมีหมา
หมาหมา
คะเหมือนมากๆ
มีจุดทุกคนว่าเหมือนหมาเลยนะหมาเนี่ยไม่
ใช่หมาที่โอเคนะเป็นหมาที่ตายแล้วก็จะตาย
มาๆใช่คูเรียร์มันเหม็นแรงก็เห็นหมาตัว
เนี้ยตาอยู่ในแม่น้ำและก็เลยลงไปแล้วก็
กินกินกินกินกินหมากินศพหมา
ระหว่างที่กำลังกินน่ะแม่น้ำเนาะก็จะรอย
ไปเรื่อยๆนะศพหมามันก็หลายหลายๆไปจนผ่าน
มาเจอกับพิกุล
อ๋อโอ้ยเรียกสงสารพี่กุล
พี่กุลทำไมค่ะคุณไม่อยู่ต้นน้ำเป็น
ระหว่างที่น้ำไหลลงมา
หมาตายอยู่ตรงนี้ภาย
แล้วพี่กุลก็อาบน้ำให้ต้นเอาน้ำไม่โอเค
แบบนี้หรอถูกต้องค่ะคนก็ล่ะจะมาเหรอคะคุณ
ฟ้าหมาก็ลงมาพร้อมกับพญาแรงด้วยนะเพราะ
พญาแล้งกำลังกิน New แล้วพิกุลก็จะแบบฉัน
อาบน้ำอยู่
เอาไม่ให้ไม่ไหวนะไม่โอเคล่ะพี่คุณก็เลย
แบบเห้ยรู้สึกโมโหหรือว่ารู้สึกโกรธฉัน
อาบน้ำอยู่ทำไมมีหมาเหม็นมากมีหมาลอยมา
พี่คุณก็เลยด่าด่าก็คือพูดไม่ดีนักเรียน
พูดไม่ดีไม่ดีที่คุณก็ด่าพญาแล้งแล้วก็
ด่าว่าทำไมถึงมากินหมาในแม่น้ำมันเหม็นไป
ไหนก็ไปไม่ไปไม่ไปแล้วก็พูดพูดพูดพูดไม่
ดีกับพญาแล้งพญาแล้งก็เลยกรุงโรส
ทำไมพิกุลถึงพูดไม่ดีล่ะฉันเป็นพญาแล้ง
ฉันก็ต้องกินอะไรที่มันเหม็นๆใช่และก็กิน
อะไรเหม็นๆอยู่แล้ว
เราพญาแล้งโกรธโกรธแล้วทำไงค่ะค่าพิกุล
เลยไหมยาแรงบอกว่าเดี๋ยวชั้นเนี่ยจะมากิน
เธอ
weeks ตอนที่คนก่อให้พี่กุลตายก่อนหรอ
เอาหรอคุณตายก่อน
ที่คุณก็แปลว่า
No  No เธอจะมากินฉันได้ยังไงฉันเป็น
เจ้าหญิงรู้ไหมฉันมีบ้านบ้านของฉันในคือ
วังใช่ไหมฉันมีคนดูแลมากเยอะแยะเลยเธอมา
กินฉันไม่ได้หรอกและคุณก็เลยกลับวังไปไม่
อาบน้ำแล้วกลับหวังไปพญาแร้งก็คิด
โกรธมากเลยพิกุลพูดไม่ดีและโกรธมากอ้าว
แล้วพญาหลังทำไงต่อคะพญาแรงก็เลย
มีรักเมจิกใช่ไหมค่ะมีอะไรมีอะไรอีกจะ
เก็บ black  magic อะไรอีกแค่แรงพูดกับคน
นี้ก็แบบไม่ธรรมดาแล้วนะก็ไม่ธรรมดาแล้ว
แต่พญาแรงเนี่ยมีเค้าเรียกว่ามีเวทมนตร์
นะอ้ำเหมือนแบบว่าเวทมนต์คืออะไรที่มัน
แบบว่าเนาะเปลี่ยนเวทมนตร์ที่พญาแล้งมี
คือพญาแรงเนี่ยสามารถเปลี่ยนจากแร้งให้
เป็นคนได้
[เพลง]
เปลี่ยนจากแรงให้เป็นคนเป็นผู้ชายหล่อ
ด้วยค่ะ
ว่าหรอกน่าจะแรงก็มีเวทมนตร์ใช่มั้ย
เวทมนตร์มันก็เปลี่ยนทั้งหมดเลยจากแร้ง
ให้เป็นคนสุดยอดลืมว่าถามว่าพญาแล้งแบบ
ไหว้แล้วก็มึงแล้วก็กลายเป็นแบบ Keith
ใช่ๆ
รอด้วยค่ะอ่ะเหรียญพญาแล้งเนี่ยก็พอเป็น
คนแล้วเนี่ยก็คิดเราต้องมีบ้านเนาะเลยไป
หาอยู่ที่ไหนดีก็ไปอยู่กับคุณตาคุณยายสอง
คนคุณตาคุณยายเนี่ยคือเป็นคนที่มีอายุ
เยอะนะหรือว่าคนแก่เนาะแล้วก็จะเรียกคุณ
ตาคุณยายเออคุณยายได้แล้วอ่าหนูเท่าไหร่
นะแต่คิดว่าน่าจะ 70  70 ประมาณ 70 ใช่
ไอ้อ้วนมัน 70 ปีใช่แล้วค่ะก็คือพอพญา
แล้งเนี่ยไปอยู่กับที่เป็นคนนะไปอยู่กับ
ตายายเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็เหมือน
ก่อนแล้วก็ช่วยป่ากับยายทำงานตากับยาย
เนี่ยไม่มีเงินฮะจนพญาแร้งเนี่ยก็ช่วยตา
กับยายทำงานทำงานแล้วก็
มีเวทมนตร์ใช่ไหมก็เลยใช้เวทมนต์อ่าเพื่อ
ทำเครื่องอะไรสร้างเงินขึ้นมาใช้เวทมนตร์
ทำให้มีเงินเยอะๆและก็เอาเงินเนี่ยมาให้
ตากับยาย
ว่ามีเงินๆ
เงินทองใช่ไหมคะเรากันได้เป็นไปเป็นแรง
เท่าไหร่ตั้งแต่แรกเพื่อ
ช่วยชีวิตแบบนี้ก็ได้นะคะถ้ากับยายเข้าหา
เงินได้ใช่หาเงินได้ถ้าก็ตกใจแล้วก็
ทำไมมีเงินเยอะขนาดนี้พญาแล้งก็เลยบอกว่า
thongyai ช่วยหน่อยได้ไหมมือ
ฉันเนี่ยชอบเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
ตากับยายช่วยไปพูดกับพระราชาให้หน่อยว่า
ฉันอยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
แทนแป้งตั้งแทนแต่งงานตากับยายก็เฮ้ยเจ้า
หญิงเป็นเจ้าหญิงไม่ใช่ไหม
ตากับยายเป็นคนธรรมดา
แต่งงานจะให้ไปแต่งงานเจ้าหญิงได้ยังไง
อือไม่โอเคแต่ว่าตากับยายไปพูดให้ไหมตา
กับยายก็คิด
แต่ไอติมผู้ชายเนี่ยไอ้พญาแล้งเนี่ยตายาย
บอกว่าคิดแล้วเหมือนจะไม่ใช่คนธรรมดาว่า
มีเงินเยอะตายายก็เลยโอเคตายายจะไปคุยกับ
พระราชาให้ตากับยายก็เลยไปคุยกับพระราชา
นะคะพ่อของเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
พระราชาก็โกรธ
เป็นตายายเป็นคนธรรมดาจะมาแต่งงานกับลูก
สาวของฉันได้ยังไง
ใช่
อะไรใช่หน้าพญาแรงหรือยังว่าหล่อมากภาษา
เห็นแล้วค่ะพระราชาก็เลยคิดหนึ่งมันก็น่า
สนใจดีไม่ใช่พระราชาก็เลยบอกว่าถ้าอย่าง
นั้น
ขอให้ทุกเธอเนี่ย 3 คนถ้าสามารถทำสะพาน
จากที่บ้านมาถึงวังหน้าได้สภานักเรียนม
ทานอันนี้จากสะพานชายทานกันอาสะพาน
มาถึงวังมาถึงวางวางใหญ่มากวางใหญ่มากใช่
เออ
สะพานเนี่ยถ้าสามารถทำมาถึงวางได้ภายใน 3
วันจะให้แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
ไม่รู้พญาแรงก็กลับบ้านกับตายายมานะคะตา
ยายก็คิดทำไม่ได้หรอกทำยังไง 3 วันทำไม่
ได้ดีอยู่จะไปทำสะพานไปถึงราชวังไปถึงวาง
เนี่ยไม่ได้แต่พญาแล้งบอกว่าตายายไม่เป็น
ไรไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวฉันทำเอง
สบายๆเพราะว่างงอยู่ถนนใช้เวลาแรงก็เลย
อ่าทำสะพานเนี่ยจากที่บ้านไปถึงหวังได้นะ
คะภายใน 3 วันทำให้พระราชาก็เลยต้องโอเค
ให้ลูกสาวเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองเนี่ยแต่งงาน
กับพญาแล้งก็แต่งงานกันนะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
วันที่แต่งงานกันนะเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองก็รู้
สึกว่ามีทำไมผู้ชายคนนี้เหม็น
มินเป็นหรอฟ้าเก่าแบบหล่อนะหล่อกันเห็น
อ่ะถ้ามิ้นไม่ไหวล่ะโอเคมา
คือไม่ใช่เหม็นปกตินักเรียนเหม็นเหมือนมี
อะไรตายค่ะเหม็นเหมือนแบบไม่เหม็นเหมือน
กลิ่นหมาตายเลยทั้งในอ่ะทำไมพญาแรงไม่เอา
เงินน่ะเอาเงินไปสื่อเลือกไปซื้อน้ำหอม
น้ำหอมแล้วก็ฉีดฉี่ใช่ไว้อ่ะนะฮะหะก็คือ
ผู้หญิงก็เลย
ยังไม่เป็นสามีภรรยากับพญาแรงนะเพราะว่า
เหม็นแค่แรงเนี่ยก็ไปบอกกับพระราชาว่าขอ
พาเจ้าหญิงไปเจอคุณพ่อกับคุณแม่ได้ไหม
เพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วฉันเนี่ยไม่ใช่ลูกของตา
กับยายฉันเป็นเจ้าชาย
จริงแล้วฉันเป็นเจ้าชายอยู่อีกเมืองนึง
ไกลมากฉันเนี่ยก็เลยจะมาขอพาเจ้าหญิงไป
เจอพ่อกับแม่ของฉันจริงๆเป็นไหมเราพระ
ราชาบอกว่าไงคะได้นะพ่อไม่ได้เพราะว่าพระ
ราชาถ้าเป็นเจ้าชายจริงๆพระราชาก็เลยต้อง
โอเคเลยโอเค
พญาแร้งเนี่ยก็ผ่าเจ้าหญิงขึ้นเรือไปนะคะ
เหลือหรออ๋อขึ้นเรือไปแล้วค่ะท่าเรือลำ
เล็กไหมคะหรือว่าลำไยมีลำใหญ่เลยค่ะ
เรื่องลำใหญ่หรอซื้อนมใหญ่เลยเอามันเรือ
มาเนี่ยเหมือนอยู่ที่เสามีเสาอยู่ที่คน
อาเสาร์วิเสาเออ
ใส่อ่ะขึ้นเรือใหม่เป็นเรือเยอะมากเลยนะ
คะเพราะว่าเป็นเจ้าหญิงเนาะเขาเป็นเจ้า
หญิงเขาต้องมีคนมีคนคนๆคนหลายๆคนและคอยดู
แลคือคนเยอะมากก็คุณครูเรียมมากค่ะคน
เดียวหน้าค่ะเข้าอากรเนี่ย
ซึ่งระหว่างที่กำลังไปเนี่ยพอทุกคนหลับ
ตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมพะยะแรงก็เลยเปลี่ยนจาก
เจ้าชายหล่อไปกลับไปเป็นพญาแล้งเหมือน
เดิมอ่าแล้วยาแล้งก็บินกลับไปหา
หมอเขาเรียกว่าอะไรทีมงานแร้งที่แม้งอ่ะ
จริงแรงทีมแรงอีกแรงแรง
เอ้อใช่กับไปหาเพื่อนหาพ่อแม่หาพี่น้อง
ใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเขาเป็นพญาแร้งไงเขาก็ต้อง
มีแรงเยอะๆเลยนะคะ
แล้วก็ยังแบบประมาณเนี้ย
เวลาที่เขาอยู่ด้วยกันเยอะๆเยอะๆตรงค่ะ
แรงก็บอกว่าทุกคนฉันจะพาไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์มี
ปาร์ตี้กินหนูเฟชาบูบุฟเฟ่ต์ชาบูนะชาบูคน
ก็เลยบอกให้แรงทุกตัวเนี่ย
ตามมาไปที่เรือที่เจ้าหญิงพิกุลอยู่ละให้
แรงทุกตัวเลยน่ะกินคนให้หมดเลยแต่
ห้ามกินพิกุลนะเพราะว่าพญาแร้งอย่าบอกว่า
เจ้าหญิงพิกุลชั้นจะกินเองห้ามใครกิน
พญาแล้งโหเป็น 100 ตัว 200 ตัวไหนก็บินมา
แล้วอยากกินคนในเรือนี้กินๆจนหมดอ้าแต่
ที่เห็นบนเรืออยู่ในก็คือตอนนี้ก็คือตาย
ทั้งหมดอายค่ะโดนไปโดนแร้งเอ้าไฟฟ้าในบอก
ว่ากินกินศพไง
คิดว่าก็ทำให้เป็นศพไงแล้วก็กินข้าวค่า
แล้วก็กินข้าเลยฮะแล้วก็กินแต่เจ้าหญิง
พิกุลเนี่ยเหมือนเจ้าหญิงที่คุณเนี่ยเขา
เป็นคนที่เป็นเจ้าหญิงแล้วหรอเราบอกว่า
เป็นคนดีหรอก็ไม่ไม่ได้ไม่ใช่คนดีค่ะนั้น
แต่ด้วยความที่เจ้าหญิงที่คุณในก็จะมีคน
ดูแลเป็นเหมือนเป็นเหมือนก่อนนะฮะเป็น
เหมือนนางฟ้าอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเป็นเป็นนาง
เจ้ารักถูกต้องหากคอยดูแลเจ้าหญิงที่คุณ
อยู่นางฟ้าเนี่ยก็เลยแอบมาบอกเจ้าหญิง
พิกุลว่า
สามีของเธอเนี่ยเป็นพญาแร้งให้เธอลงไป
ข้างล่างของเรือแล้วก็ไปแอบอยู่เต็มที่
ข้างล่าง
ฉันลงไปข้างล่างเลยเราอยู่ที่คุณก็เลยใช่
ลงมาแอบอยู่ข้างล่างนะคะไม่ให้พญาแรงเห็น
ซึ่งซึ่ง
หลบได้สำเร็จเรื่องจบยังไม่จบค่ะนะคะยาย
แต่ว่าเจ้าหญิงที่คุณจะตายไหม
อ้าวคิดว่ามันคงต้อง
วีดีโอหน้าทำเพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลา
แล้วใช่ไหมคะคือเรื่อง
เต็ม
ที่ก็เรียนทุกคนนักเรียนกำลังเหรอตื่น
เต้นตื่นเต้นเจ้าหญิงที่คนจะตายไหม
เจอกันวีดีโอหน้า / ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้ว
นะคะว่าพี่ค่ะได้ค่ะครูฟ้าเดี๋ยวไว้เจอ
กันวีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนได้เลยค่ะนัก
เรียนงวดนี้ครูบากับครูเรียมไปก่อนนะคะ
สวัสดีไงเขาสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ